hah dad we get really good and you know
I want to thank you too babe for the
help that you gave my mom my mom loves
you you really you can see you saw how
[ __ ] up I am with my mom yeah it's a
weird family are we allowed to be
talking about yeah go ahead um so what I
noticed on her trip to LA was you guys
have a very vocal love where you say big
I love yous but you're very little on
the gesture very avoidant um they don't
want to pick her up from the airport
they don't drop her off at the airport
they don't really spend a lot of time
with her it's very concentrated like
bursts of time together like they'll
spend 10 minutes with her and then all
of a sudden and then they'll be like ok
kalila like you you take her around town
so and then you just don't really spend
time with each other
mm-hm you can only handle each other in
short bursts and none of you guys listen
to each other mm-hmm it's kind of uh it
was a very I loved her company I loved
her but it was a very head-scratching
weekend for me where I'm like okay
that's one way to show love I guess you
were saying we played hot potato with my
dad's ashes yeah you guys were playing
hot potato with your dad's ashes his mom
okay this is what happened that's our
wine real quick let's rewind that's what
a wine real quick the whole reason why
she was here in the [ __ ] yes well she
gives me [ __ ] the whole reason why is
because she doesn't want the ashes okay
and then you didn't pick up her phone
call so she calls if right she kept
calling me I knew it was about the
[ __ ] ashes mm-hmm give me an email it
to you or whatever right I go no keep I
spent extra $60 or $80 to keep the ashes
in the mortuary right and they go why
cuz I know my mom thinks that like Happ
because the ashes are split into two
boxes right so my mom thinks that half
of my dad's ghost is gonna haunt her if
she has one half of the box right so she
kept both boxes at the mortuary and I
said let me because she's not gonna want
them so
we might I might pick him up a year from
now let me pay you extra right but no
she brings these [ __ ] two boxes right
back to LA well I get a phone call on
Thursday night and she says kalila Bobby
is not picking up my phone call
I need can you buy me a ticket to go to
LA tomorrow and I was like well why
what's what's happening what's the
occasion cuz you know she was supposed
to be here in a couple weeks right and
she's like oh I'm picking up the ashes
tomorrow morning and I don't want to
spend the night with the ashes so I have
to fly to LA the same day to drop off
the ashes there was a whole reason why
she was here Yeah right so and then like
I didn't want the ashes so I told Steve
to take bolt and he doesn't want both
he's scared of it so I got [ __ ] take
I guess the other half oh yeah also I'm
not
I also yeah it is but I also don't know
Han Gilbert yep I also don't know the
percentage if I open up the box oh gosh
how much of those ashes is fully my dad
that's what creeps me out if it was
fully your dad I'm okay with that but
what if there are others that's what I'm
saying other energies definitely others
that's right because you know that that
that what is that this furnace
every single time right so no you know
me there's some or some kind of person
we've he's offended in the past yeah yes
I'm just saying it's not purely I don't
feed guarantee it 100% my dad's ashes
that's impossible in my mind mm-hm so
what is it we don't know we don't have
been down there our podcast wouldn't
keep it down there well it's gonna be
behind you'll Bert the whole time you
see we're yeah but you know what's cute
is the photo my brother had for the box
it's really cute yeah it's hard to look
at it's a good pick up my dad it's
totally good I don't honestly I don't I
don't I I can't even it's so funny I'll
lay down I'll just be in the backyard
vaping and I'll just get this random
thought of my dad
you know completely alter my day and my
mood from then on it's such a weird
sensation of like I thought I think I'm
running from the fact that he died I
know I keep saying it because you know
it's what three or four episodes in now
I'm still dealing with it I'm sorry is
what I want to be real okay here's
another thing I want to say tell the
comics we've had a couple of fall outs
I've tried to fill in those gaps with
comics that have asked me a 10,000 times
to be on my [ __ ] podcast if you get
these windows up opportunity to Tiger
belly just [ __ ] do it I I'm whatever
it's my mom again look see every time we
just read it I don't know what this text
is it's probably a nice loving text and
you should respond lovingly I've been in
bed for two days oh well you laughing he
loves everything you love everything you
do that don't like everything I'm gonna
see it again this should make you laugh
John look at him though
i double-dare days okay whenever I try
to get up I couldn't oh my god because
I've been having dizzy spells this is
the first time I'll recover from it
don't worry I'll I'll never leave my
boys alone love you so much good night
oh my god she's dying what the [ __ ] is
going on